hey guys this is Pete peppers with candy
crush soda saga tips calm and this is a
candy crush soda saga I love 170
walkthrough some tips in the commentary
I've been having a lot of questions
about this one lately in my group so I'm
gonna go ahead and play through and talk
about what we need to do in order to
beat this it's a tough level similar to
a lot of the early tough ones like level
40 and level 70 but we have a sort of a
bottleneck on the board it makes it a
little bit tougher so what we're going
to do is we want to make a bunch of
straight candies in the beginning and we
sort of want to try to figure out where
the bear at the bottom is so that we can
attack it so just making stripes get
getting rid of some of the layers and
just looking things over to see where we
can best use them now this is a one
thing that you want to do is use that
striped to clear out that bottom row and
we're also going to be looking for
horizontal stripes that we can use to
match with the fish and now we can see
that the bear is across the middle here
so we'll just clear out a couple other
rows and see which direction he's going
because they do move around a little bit
so you kind of want to go towards the
part of the board where they where he is
and you know we want to clear out some
space the bottom we can't do that right
now but as soon as we can we want to do
that so that we can set up some combos
down there clear out things pretty quick
so yeah the purple match will give us a
little more room and now we can see he's
on the left side and the men also just
try to get things cascading like that it
always helps when you have a color bomb
at the bottom like this ideally you want
to use it in a combo but it right now
it's kind of stuck so we'll see what
happens we might want it might make more
sense to just use it by itself to open
up things but right now we're moving
along pretty good you notice I'm not
really paying attention to the bears at
the top they're gonna they're gonna
mostly get removed as we go so no need
to really focus a lot of tension on
those now we have this will be good
a rat plus a strut color bomb will clear
out a lot of the space for us collected
both there's at the top and now we can
just sort of use our last 14 moves to
finish the job this can also be hard to
on the sides especially because the
candy doesn't fall that way so
definitely taking my time the fish
aren't super effective because there's
other pieces ice that they might go
after so kind of decided to leave that
fish where it was for now and maybe
it'll come in handy later
so we got all the different colors down
there it's not ideal but some of eight
moves I'm no need to get worried and now
we can let's drop this yellow down here
and finish it off so that's pretty much
it it's a frustrating level I know but
you know if you follow the things that I
said you should be able to get it before
too long I hope that's helped please
take a second to like the video and make
sure you subscribe to our channel to get
more videos with commentary so that you
can get through the toughest levels I'll
be back to make more soon so I'll talk
to you then